حدث اليوم
المستشار الالماني يزور واشنطن يستقبله
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ولا شك ان
الموضوع الروسي الاوكراني سيطغى على
اللقاء بين الرجلين لاحظنا في الاونه
الاخيره تذبذبا اوروبيا في التعامل مع
موضوع المساعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا قد
تتضح الرؤيه اكثر بعد هذه الزياره لا اطيل
عليكم معي من بون الصحفي عارف جابوا اهلا
وسهلا بك استاذ عارف
اولا كيف يتفاعل الاعلام الالماني مع هذه
الزياره طبعا يعني الزياره تحظى باهتمام
كبير في الاعلام الماني هناك تعليقات على
هذه
الزياره وتوقعات وتحليلات طبعا يعني لن
تتضح الامور حتى تنتهي الزياره ولكن مركزت
عليه الصحف يعني والاعلام بشكل عام هو ان
هذه هي الزياره الثانيه للمستشار الالماني
عام وشهر يعني الزياره الاولى كانت قبل
غزو اوكرانيا باسبوعين والان هذه الزياره
والملفت في هذه الزياره ايضا التي تركز
عليها الاعلام يعني الوفد صغير يعني لا
يرافقه يعني مسؤولون اخرون او من قطاع
الاقتصاد او اي رجال اعمال وحتى يعني وفد
اعلامي يغيب عن هذه الزياره وهذا ما كان
ملفتا يعني كثيرا للاعلام بالضافه الى
تناول مواضيع الزياره
نعم
هل جاء اولى هل يذهب اولاف شورس الى
واشنطن
لاستشاره
جو بايدن ام بصراحه
لمزيد من الاملاءات احاديه الجانب من
واشنطن
يعني ليست يعني بهذا الشكل
املائيه بشكل تام ولكن نعلم ان هناك تنسيق
يعني منذ البدايه قال المستشار الالماني
انه لنخطوه دون التنسيق مع الحلفاء
والشركاء وعلى راسهم طبعا الولايات
المتحده يعني راينا ان المانيا يعني لم
تتخذ الكثير من القرارات فيما يتعلق
بتسليح وفيما يتعلق بالحرف اوكرانيا يعني
قبل ان تتخذ ايضا واشنطن وموقفها كانت
تتشاور مع واشط وكان هناك يعني تواصل مع
الرئيس الامريكي بين الرئيس الامريكي
والمستشار الالماني يعني اعتقد انها
استشارات وايضا عن الشيء من الضغوط
الامريكيه ان صح التعبير ايضا يعني لكي
المانيا يعني لا تتردد بعض الشيء كما حصل
في الاونه الاخيره او كما يعني يقول
البعض ولكن اعتقد درجه الاولى من اجل
التنسيق حول الخطوات القادمه
وتشاور بين الطرفين
في تحرك مماثل يعني قبل قبل اسابيع الى
الناحيه الشرقيه لاوروبا الى الصين تحديدا
اشعرنا
المستشار الالماني اولى
بوجود استقلاليه المانيه داخل المنظومه
الاوروبيه هل هذا يتجسد اليوم اكثر مع
واشنطن
نعم يعني نعرف ان علاقات المانيا مع الصين
وثيقه جدا من الناحيه الاقتصاديه وهناك
يعني اعتماد على الصين كما هناك اعتماد
صيني على المانيا سواء من الناحيه
التجاريه والتبادل التجاري بين البلدين
ومن الناحيه التكنولوجيه يعني راينا ايضا
ان امريكا حاولت ان تمارس بعض الضغوط على
المانيا لكي تقلص علاقاتها مع الصين
والمانيا تسير في هذا الاتجاه لتقليص
علاقاتها وتحقيق شيئا ما من الاستقلاليه
عن الصين لكي تفك الارتباط وتستفيد وتحاول
ان تستفيد من الدرس الروسي وراينا هناك
ايضا بعض التباين في الموقف الامريكي
والالماني فيما يتعلق بالصين يعني امريكا
تقود بما يشبه حرب اقتصاديه مع صيغه حول
الضغط عليها بينما المانيا يعني ليست بهذه
الحد علاقتها مع
المانيا وامريكا بالدرجه الاولى يعني
كبيرين للصين يعني المانيا وامريكا نعم
استاذ عارف جابوا طبعا هناك حديث عن عن
مساعده عسكريه المانيه لاوكرانيا طبعا
واكيد هذا الكلام حاضر في هذا اللقاء
المنتظر بين بين
طبعا يعني مثلا الاوكرانيه وتسليح
اوكرانيا ودعمها هي على راس جدول الاعمال
الزياره التي هي زياره عمل طبعا قصيره جدا
هذه الزياره حيث ليست هناك على البرنامج
اي لقاءات مع اطراف اخرى سوى مع الرئيس
بايدن وستكون يعني حتى
في البدايه
المستشارين المقربين سيحضرون اللقاء ثم
سيكون اللقاء خلف الابواب المغلقه
انفراديا بين الرجلين واعتقد هنا سيتم
تناول مسائل حساسه لا يريد الطرفان ان
تخرج الى الاعلام او ان يعلم بها الاخرون
قبل اوانها
وربما تتعلق بتسليح اوكرانيا باسلحه اخرى
او التنويعها او تحسينها يعني هذا بان كان
هناك حديث على الطيران لا اعتقد الان سيتم
يعني التركيز على هذا الموضوع لكن ربما
ايضا يتعلق بمستقبل الصراع في اوكرانيا
لانه قبل يومين يعني كان هناك وقل
للمستشار الالم ان الحلفاء الغربيين
يبحثون لما يشبه ضمانات امنيه لاوكرانيا
مستقبلا اذا انتهت الحرب يعني ربما يتم
تناول في هذا الاجتماع او التطرق الى ما
مساله ما بعد الحرب والضمانات التي يمكن
تقديمها لاوكرانيا لان اطاله الحرب يعني
ترهق اوروبا وترهق امريكا طبعا بدرجه
الاولى وعلى راسها المانيا لذلك يريدون
ايضا هم يعني انتهاء الحرب ولكن ليس باي
ثمن اعتقد هذا ايضا سيكون على الجدول
لعمله تناوله والضمانات التي يمكن تقديمها
لاوكرانيا وروسيا ايضا لكن لن يعلن عن ذلك
الان ولذلك هذا الاجتماع مغلق وبين
الرجلين فقط نعم استاذ عارف جابوا هناك
هناك جدل داخل حلف شمال الاطلسي حول
توسيعه ليضم يعني دولا كاف لندن مثلا التي
تنتظر موافقه تركيه الى غير ذلك كيف هو
النقاش الالماني حول هذا الموضوع
طبعا يعني المانيا بتضغط بهذا الاتجاه
وتحاول يعني ان تمارس نفوذها او علاقاتها
الوثيقه مع تركيا نعرف هناك علاقه قويه
بين المانيا وتركيا سواء تاريخيا او بسبب
وجود الجاليه لكن يعني الموقف التركي الان
يعني متعلق ونعرف ان التركيه على ابواب
انتخابات ولذلك يعني المانيا الان ايضا
تتريث بعض الشيء لكي تنتهي الانتخابات
وتنجلي الامور فيما اذا كان اردوغان سيبقى
في الحكم او انه سيرحل لان الوضع سيختلف
في تركيا ويعتمد على انتخابات لان يعني
الان هذه الانتخابات فمساله عضويه فنلندا
والسويد يعني تقريبا شبه مجمده الان خاصه
بعد الزلزال وانشغال تركيا واوروبا بهذا
لكن المانيا تحاول ان تلعب دورا ولكن
اعتقد ان الامر سيتوقف على نتائج
الانتخابات القادمه وفيما اذا كان اردو
سيبقى في الحكم ام انه سيرحل نبقى مع هذا
التحرك تحرك المستشار الالماني او لاف
شورت الى واشنطن الى البيت الابيض نعرف ان
محرك الاتحاد الاوروبي قائم على الثنائي
الالماني الفرنسي
هكذا على الاقل ينظر اليه هنا في باريس
كيف ينظر اليه في برلين
طبعا يعني في برلين ايضا يعني في المانيا
يقولون محرك الاتحاد الاوروبي وما فرنسا
والمانيا لا يمكن تصورها الاتحاد الاوروبي
او اتخاذ اي قرار يعني مهم بدون موافقه
فرنسا والمانيا نعرف اذا المانيا وفرنسا
يعني وافقت على قرار ما واجراء ما فتستطيع
ان تمارس نفوذها والضغوطها على الدول
الاخرى والدول الاخرى ايضا يعني
تسير خلفهما ولكن يعني هذا المحرك يعني
لم يتعطل ولكن يعني تباطا في الاونه
الاخيره لكن اعتقد ان الاجتماع الذي حصل
الشهر الاول من هذا العام بين الحكومه
الفرنسيه والحكومه الالمانيه يعني حاول
تجاوز هذه الخلافات لكن يعني يبقى هناك
بعض التباين في المواقف الاستراتيجيات بين
الدولتين ولكن في النهايه دائما يصلون الى
حل وسط يعني وبدونهما يعني لا يمكن الات
الاوروبي ان يستمر ويضعف كثيرا نعرف
اقتصاديا المانيا هي الاولى وعسكريا فرنسا
هي الاولى وهي القوه النوويه
الوحيده ولذلك يعني لا بد للاتحاد
الاوروبي ان يكون هناك دائما تنسيق
الفرنسي والمانيا والسير مع واذا كان هناك
يعني صراع او خلاف او تنافس بينهما ينعكس
حتى على الاتحاد الاوروبي وقراراته ويضعفه
حتى الموقف من الصين ايضا لا بد من
التنسيق بين الطرفين لكن بالنهايه يعني
يبقى هناك بعض التبائن فيما يتعلق
بالمصالح الوطنيه لكل دولتين لكن هناك
دائما تفاهم وتفهم ايضا من الجانبين لذلك
استاذ عارف جابو تشعرنا الاداره الامريكيه
احيانا انها لا تهتم كثيرا بالمصالح
الاوروبيه هل للمستشاره الالماني القدره
على اقناع الاداره الامريكيه
بفهم المخاوف الاوروبيه
يعني كانت هناك مطالب للمستشار يعني
الاوساط الاقتصاديه طلبت من مستشار
الالماني ايضا ان يبحث ويحاول الضغط على
الجانب الامريكي فيما يتعلق
ببرنامج الامريكي لمكافحه التضخم وللحد من
التضخم ستساعد الشركات الامريكيه وتمارس
نوعا من الحمائيه يعني المانيا تستطيع ان
تمارس بعض الضغط لان حجم التبادل التجاري
بين الدولتين يعني كبير جدا يعني العام
الماضي الصادرات الالمانيه الى الولايات
المتحده كانت 156 مليار دولار
واستوردت منها
حوالي 95 مليار دولار يتبادل التجاري كبير
هذا عن الدول الاوروبيه الاخرى يمكن
لالمانيا ولكن سيكون اقوى لو ان دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي والاتحاد الاوروبي يعني
معا بموقف موحد بحث ذلك مع الامريكي وقد
تم بحث ذلك واعتقد ان رئيسه المفوضيه
الاورو التي ستزور واشنطن ايضا الاسبوع
القادم ستركز على هذا الامر طبعا دائما
المثل الاوكرانيه حاضر على جدول الاعمال
لكن ستركز ايضا على المصالح الاقتصاديه
لاوروبا خلال محادثاتها مع الجانب
الامريكي والرئيس جو بايدن وايضا امريكا
سيتحاول التقرب من اوروبا ايضا تريد ان
تكسب اوروبا وهي تضغط عليها مساله الصين
يعني سيكون هناك نوعا ما من تبادل المصالح
بين الاوروبيين والامريكيين سواء في الصين
او في اوكرانيا في جانب اخرى يعني نعرف ان
كل بلد امريكا بالدرجه الاولى تهمها
مصالحها بالدرجه الاولى قبل المصالح
شركائها الاوروبيين استاذ عارف جابوا من
بون شكرا لك